[Music]
nice hair Baloo PewDiePie or should I
say off-brand jacksepticeye you're such
a big strong man why do you always cry
like a little [ __ ] you know you could
try to be smart and funny in life so did
you get all those pubes on your face
from sucking all that day oh there's a
human under that acne holy [ __ ]
so I'm having a hard time figuring this
out which is bigger your hand or your
ego so you're a former gymnast
oh so you failed that and then decided
to fail at YouTube you know chika to
steer your walls because she just wants
to get away from you you know you're
such a little [ __ ] it could be a good
friend for chika you think with all that
YouTube ad revenue you could buy
yourself some more friends you're too
ugly for anybody to love you you're not
clever enough to do YouTube but there's
one saving grace you're the perfect
height for sucking dick and I figured
you're good at that because you suck at
pretty much everything else so you just
suck on four subscribers and views right
so I know why you bought you go
love you
the one thing I remember from wrestling
too is I know why all your relationships
[Music]
failed when you dropped route when they
saw it so the real reason they call you
marvel sparkle is because of your
obsession hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to oh sir the
insult simulator the game where you come
up with the creative insults that you
wish to dawn upon all those unsuspecting
sons of [ __ ] out there and it's got a
lot of mustaches with something that I
can very much respect so ow my button
learned insult so your smarmy [ __ ] wagon
what the [ __ ] temper winkled sack of
potato skins you you you'll be got in
the sack of octopus excrement you Rempel
skinned Rempel you wrinkled skin leather
leather testicles
bow bow legged sally sacker of a [ __ ]
nut you piece of garbage [ __ ] ramming
ass blasting [ __ ] lloyd okay anyway i'm
gonna learn how to answer how again my
button okay thank you mr. J's shuffle
bottom i don't start with something
straightforward okay let's see your your
face your face no not not gonna do that
or i fireman your wife your was against
you don't worry sir
I'm a gentleman I don't believe that for
a second oh she's very naughty have and
everyone in town knows it okay if you
have a conjunction I don't know what the
word conjunction means oh now I do I'll
go easy on you and end my sentence yeah
well that was your mistake you you you
you you you red nose though but the the
[ __ ] you that's who you are
you're your [ __ ] you the red nose bigger
basket alright well that was your
mistake see and looks like your math
teacher I'm counting I'm hoping that
your math teacher was not exceptionally
hot and I'm also banking on the
possibility that your wife wasn't your
math teacher looks like dull and ugly
okay alrighty then speaking of hands you
now have two additional insult
components in your hand whoo thank you
now introduce the component to end your
insult it's the one with an exclamation
mark ah let's see all right I can do
this I got I got I got I got this some
dog some dog smells over don't take your
mother you can sip key once to draw two
new insult components to replace the
ones you have in your hand
uh-huh okay I don't want to do that oh I
have a custom hand oh good I got your
mother some dog smells of your mother
ah no no not that one now and I have
proof no oh god no and ah no god damn it
ah some dog smells of your mother and I
have proof you [ __ ] ah god damn it ah
and a muppet and and your cousin's car
something happened between your mom and
your dog in your cousin's car sir
I'm done smells of your mother and your
cousin's car yeah this place looks like
a public loo that wasn't even it's not
even my place my feelings I shall have
to rethink my life good as it should be
okay you know what I've learned enough I
was hoping there was gonna be some
customization here but everything seems
to be locked
hmm that guy looks like an [ __ ] wow
this lady looks like a mean Sally sacked
cross eyed piece of [ __ ] with
everybody's Popeye arms why does
everyone have tumors in their arms I'm
not exactly me you know close enough ah
I'll do this for them come at me you
Holly mocked piece of [ __ ] come at me
you you poorly mustachioed man that
smells of your mother's underwear oh god
no oh jeez Oh God this parrot is this
parrot posed nude for your mother and it
killed it oh jeez Wow
my sister changes into my father that
actually kind of cuts me deeply
yeah well power toes is nude for your
mother
honestly I'm impressed I have no idea
how that happens your sense of style
belongs in one of those cages I'm
already done this one's gonna cut to the
bone oh don't even try
or insults you're never gonna be able to
get here well my teacher can't dance so
it's good that my style belongs in one
of those cages who taught or born HP
take some of these with you while you're
at it
your father was defeated by your mother
and is very naughty it's not holy-shit
defeated by your mother and take some of
that with you even though they didn't
seem to do a whole lot well your
father's gonna get it again your face
and I'm taking the end you're not
getting the end this time your face and
your country are silly and look like dot
dot I'll continue this is don't kill me
on this one just don't kill me on this
one this all can hang on I definitely do
that's a 100% true but that doesn't need
to be pull out into this you're facing
your country you're silly and look like
your mother and I better go first on
this because I need to go first and have
bad breath I'm done I hope you can't
make a car don't kill me come on this is
a good one and your country are silly
and look like your mother and I could
have complained you that was my first
argument first real one anyway alright
fine you know what I'm not gonna deal
with this it's gonna have another row
you saggy bald
of markiplier mucus I don't know by the
lake okay okay there's this dead body
belong to you by chance to put my teacup
on that murdered this poor man to have
tea on his rotting corpse how could I
murder him when I was hiding in a
shrubbery with my rifle the whole
morning all right
you might have a perfect alibi but you
can't deny this okay your mother tells
dirty jokes at funerals and with Santa
clothes you commoner you mother
funerals and wears second-hand clothes
commoner again and I have both in my
pocket baby you're gonna get it has bad
breath you cross-eyed inbred muck spouts
your mother is an uneducated nincompoop
oh well I don't think that's true
your mother wait okay I'm gonna get your
math teacher first it's really quite a
benefit to go first and your mother have
tiny feet I'm on a mother roll get it
get it get it you added your dad your
dad your daddy and your mother have tiny
feet hell yeah Bassel really I look like
my face sorta murderer but you sure have
a filthy mouth good boy good boy and
that is how you win an argument in any
capacity throw anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this one it was kind of fun
to be able to insult people or learn to
insult people and I hope you enjoyed the
little sketch at the beginning
I insulted my friends and then Tyler
just hey one see once Tyler sticks to a
certain train of thought it is
impossible to deviate him from that
thought process but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching there are
bloopers from that little session that
you guys can see very soon and I hope
you're enjoying all the live-action
something we're doing because it's so
much fun so thanks again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]